that deserves applause oh my gosh
walk into the closet okay
you designed all this yes this is
incredible thank you
first of all i'm going to ask some rude
questions go for it
give me some numbers here oh no clue
don't ask i have
literally no clue i'm scared to count
okay and don't forget that this isn't
the only closet in the house right
current closet then there is the other
closet of the clothes that are not
currently being worn
well if we get emotional for a minute
here though what i'm
seeing here is you led such a restricted
life before
and now you are oh yes being everything
you want to be
does this closet represent that well you
have to realize that to me
what you know clothing people think of
some people think clothing is frivolous
or like fashion why does it matter
but you have to realize that my whole
life i was forced to cover myself
right so basically the only parts of my
body that were showing were my hands
and my face you had to be the most
simple quiet meek mild
um and obedient person
right and you needed to attract zero
attention being covered up meant that i
only mattered as an addendum to a man
being covered up meant
my life had to be this big because he
shouldn't have a bad thought
well you know what now your closet alone
is this big exactly
well to me clothing says i matter
on my own not whether a man sees me and
disregards me or man sees me and is
attracted to me
that's not my problem say it again yes
not my problem this closet moves
yes we see this on the show indeed it is
reminiscent to me of do you remember
that scene in clueless
yes that's where i got the idea are you
totally i was like
wow that's brilliant i love this movie
uh-huh like let me just grab a little
yves saint laurent i've never asked
someone in their closet before who are
you wearing but who are you wearing
valentino
okay absolutely let me let me put the
sail around back where she belongs
thank you okay so as you know you've
seen it before
but i see chanel i see more valentino
now my difficulty is and again
i love being my size i'm perfectly
comfortable as i am i do think that god
has a fantastic
sense of humor that he made me the
global ceo
with the world's largest women so i love
that but the other thing is that i have
a great difficulty in reaching things
right you don't have this problem you
are perfectly proportioned and
fabulously gorgeous
me on the other hand i walk into a
supermarket i'm climbing like a
three-year-old
okay to reach the thing on the top shelf
so i wanted to avoid that
in my own closet so in order to do that
i went to these amazing closet makers in
italy
and i told them is there a way that we
can move the closet
out of the closet then it can come down
down down down
to my level you're moving the ceiling
julia is that fabulous
and then you do a little roll
and you have all your clothing
at your fingertips without having to
stand on your tippy
okay are you kidding me
with this julia this is what i can't see
you guys
there's some hide and seek to be had yes
hi hi how are you good to see you
absolutely where are you well i'm i'm in
between the gucci and the
ysl thank you great yeah
that deserves applause oh my gosh that
is incredible
it's like narnia in here you know you
never know what door's gonna open
all right what is give me one piece that
pops out to you amongst all of these so
honestly i'm standing right here and
this is
i just got this from louis vuitton
hospital
cute little number a bit dangerous when
the wind blows
just letting you know look red is your
color definitely red is why can you tell
the hangers are red and have my name on
them
so why this piece because louis vuitton
took my
daughters and me to champagne like the
actual
place in france where they make
champagne right
and i had such an extraordinary it was
just so
much fun because hold that up for us so
in louis vuitton
you went to the champaign region and
drink dom perignon yes
not just on familial but something
called p2 which is
plentitude 2 which apparently is like
the oldest champagne you can have and it
has to be made in a particular way
it's a lot of okay it's really cool the
oldest most exclusive champagne you
could possibly drink great that dress
deserves that yes
so these are probably
the most important piece of clothing in
my class i know they look like plain
leather leggings but
they have a very very important story to
them so when i grew up
women as i said have to be covered head
to toe and you are not allowed
to wear pants when i left my community i
was too scared to put them on
because i had been taught that if you
wear pants
you and your mother are going to hell
because your mother is going to hell
because she didn't teach you properly so
i had been out of the community probably
nine months and i still had not put on a
pair of pants
and i'm in milan my first fashion week
so i'm in milan and i'm walking and
there's this woman
this breathtakingly beautiful woman and
she is walking down the street
wearing a pair of black leather leggings
and i know this is going to sound creepy
i literally start following her
i'm not following her i'm following the
leggings i am
drawn and fascinated by these leggings
so finally after a few minutes i get the
courage to come over to her and say hi
literally in the middle of the street in
italy i'm julia
where did you get your fans so she told
me that they were a pair of black
samurai leggings so i girded my lines
steal my courage
and walked in to saint laurent and said
with as much courage as i could muster i
would like to see
the black leather leggings please and i
felt like i had just i don't know
gone to the moon you know done something
super brave
so i go and i buy these leather leggings
and i go to my hotel
and i put them on my bed and then i'm
too scared to wear them
so my pants and i have like communion
with each other
for a few days finally finally i get up
the courage and i decide you know what
if i'm going to be killed i'm going to
be killed in a pair of
black santa leather leggings that's the
way to go
that's the way to go so you did not
get killed you are here i am here so far
so good so far
and i will never these stay with me
always no matter what
these are the lucky lucky these are the
lucky leggings these are the leggings
that started
true freedom for me julia we have to
talk about the shoes
okay okay so these are your shoes you
are
i'm guessing built this that is correct
it's like a lazy susan for shoes
lazy shoes in a guest estimate on how
many pairs of shoes you want
is it in the hundreds probably probably
probably yes because
i'm seeing lots of gucci gucci gucci goo
uh why all the gucci
so i am a size four which is a
ridiculous size
okay and so see now that is an
appropriate
logical legitimate size where that every
brand makes
now gucci and prada have done something
very lovely for me
they have allowed me to design my own
shoes
and customize their styles
like what we're saying is that you are
such an incredible icon in the fashion
industry
that you have gucci and prada on speed
dial and they let you
use their shoe molds to make custom
shoes yeah it's pretty nice
okay for the nice miranda priestly and
she can move on over because
you can call gucci and prada i can say
that you know
i would love to show you some pairs for
my brand but
a museum is going to be using them in an
exhibit
so i gave every pair i own
to them so i'm afraid i don't have any
to show you that's an interview first
for me
she can't show us her shoes because
they're getting their own display at a
museum
got it okay everything started with
shoes yeah and
tell us what that key was that made your
shoes so successful
well i think you know when i came into
the fashion industry which is
really shocking to me still today
people still thought it was okay for
women to suffer for beauty
and when i first started i was told
julia do not use the word comfort it's a
dirty world
it's a dirty word in the fashion
industry and i thought to myself well
that's outrageous and i said we're still
making clothing for women that hurt
we're making shoes for women that
torture them we say beauty is pain
no we should not say that men don't say
beauty is pain why should we
your shoes had this incredible pattern
right yes uncomfortable exactly they had
two patents pending
um one of them was on the shape of the
arch
basically we altered the arch by two
millimeters
which basically elongated the arch
from this to here and basically what it
did is that it
even the pressure points across your
entire foot so your
weight of your body was resting on your
entire foot as opposed to the ball of
your foot
and so i wanted to eradicate this
concept of suffering for beauty
so that was basically the idea of my
shoe line all right julia you reinvented
shoes you reinvented closet
let's go i did wonder did you keep
any clothing items from that previous
life
i put them in a pile and burned them to
the skies
and seen